the clip of amy schumer saying that ryan
done joke kind of went viral when it was
like right chris
let's be clear that
amy schumer was not uh saying anything
disparaging of ryan dunn sure her the
thing was that uh she you know there was
nothing
like wrong about what she said oh your
friend died and you know that's so sad
but like i was along with everybody else
thinking man why couldn't it have been
stevo right you know so it's like
i mean i don't know i think i think she
caught a lot of uh
of grief for that that i i don't think
that
well i'm not saying we should pile onto
her i just saw it
recently i uh actually you know myself i
got carried away in in all of the grief
that was being thrown at her and and i
at one point reached out to uh
you know to just try to
say hey like i was [ __ ]
i'm not proud of how i handled this
situation i was i was a jerk and i
contributed to it and uh we made
we uh made everything really nice and
now whenever i see amy schumer getting
griefed for that to this day just i
don't like it i don't think she deserves
it and it bothers me
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
[Applause]
me